former un Ambassador Nikki Haley is with
us uh Ambassador good to talk to you
good to have you
back thanks Sean it's great to be with
you and how embarrassing this all
is boy it really is embarrassing but
it's not just embarrassing it's also
scary I've been spending an awful lot of
time in the last couple of weeks talking
about all the people that are coming in
through our Southern border that Joe has
kept open coming from Iran and Syria
other Middle Eastern countries countes
but many others are also coming from
China many others are coming from Russia
why do you think they're coming from
those countries to this
country there there's no good coming out
of it it is really serious that you have
I mean just a thousand that we know of
from Yemen and Lebanon and Iran that
doesn't count Afghanistan you're talking
about China and Russia all it takes is
one Sean it just takes one to have a 911
moment and we have got to secure this
border you've got got to stop having
that flow come in you know you look at
the fact that Hamas broke through a
barrier to do all that they did in
Israel we don't even have a barrier
they're coming through and we're not
vetting them we don't know who they are
we don't know what's happening we've got
to start paying attention to the threats
in this world and we've got to start
realizing that there are enemies out
there that hate us and if we don't start
securing and protecting ourselves
something bad's going to
happen now neither the Department of
Homeland Security secretary orcus nor
FBI director Ray can say with any
certainty how many people have entered
the country illegally and how many
people may have ties to terrorism now
Ron Johnson of Wisconsin the senator he
thinks it's somewhere around 8 million
illegal immigrants that Joe Biden has
allowed into the country unvetted and
that includes the quote gotway my
question to you is um I I don't have any
doubt that among those 8 million people
that there are people with terrorist
ties people that will plot plan and
scheme a 911 or worse I would say it's
100% certainty but I'll add this caveat
I pray to God that I'm
wrong 240,000 came in last month and 13
known terrorists suspected terrorists
came in through our border last month
that we know of 13 how many do we not
know of and it really is a dereliction
of Duty there's not an American in this
country that feels safe right now for
what's happening we've got to put an end
to it and it's not that hard defund
Sanctuary cities put 25,000 more border
patrol and Ice agents on the ground and
let them do their job stop Catch and
Release and let's do catch and Deport
but the main thing go back to the remain
and Mexico policy so they never step
foot on our soil in the first place they
have to process from there we have to do
it our schools can't continue to take
this our hospitals can't continue to
take this we can't continue to have the
crime and we can't afford to put
Americans at risk and that's what Joe
Biden's doing every day he's putting
America at risk and a president has one
job and that's to keep their people safe
and he has not done
that let me ask you this and you're in a
pretty unique position to answer this
and it's and we talked about this the
last time you were on the program and
that has to do with these globalist
organizations for example tell me if I'm
wrong that the United Nations of which
we pay billions of taxpayer dollars
every year to fund it has been
historically anti-American and
anti-semitic is that a true
statement that's a true
statement okay my question is why are we
funding it why do we bother to
participate then we can go to the wh uh
another globalist organization did they
not cover up for what they knew about
China and their role with the covid-19
virus is that
true that is true and they're bought and
paid paid for by the Chinese and that
played out in real
time okay then we have the WF the world
economic Forum uh it seems that the
world economic forum is about taking
American money and redistributing our
money around the world uh when we have
what 35 36 trillion dollar in debt uh is
that an accurate
statement that's an accurate statement
and I'll add to that we gave $50 billion
to countries to foreign aid to countries
and we're giving it to countries that
hate America I we have to stop giving
money to countries that hate America and
yes the world economic forum is full of
them okay next question so Donald Trump
got us out of the the Paris climate
Accords um we paid the bulk of money for
it Joe Biden brought us back into it and
correct me uh uh Ambassador if I'm wrong
Governor if you prefer uh but isn't it
true that the Paris Accords affords
China and Indian developing Nation
status so they pay next to nothing
compared to the amount of money that
we're putting into that globalist
deal well that's what's happening at the
United Nations so they are consider
China is considered a developing C
country at the United Nations which we
said was absolutely ridiculous because
they obviously are not a developing
country the problem with the
organizations it's the reason we got out
of the Human Rights Council it's the
reason that we stopped any us Aid going
to the Palestinian refugee organization
it's the reason that the first year I
was Ambassador we cut a billion dollars
off the top at the UN all of these
organizations the World Health
Organization we shouldn't be a part of
it we should get out of it and we should
stay out of it this all started when we
helped China get into the World Trade
Organization we saw that as well bottom
line is we need to be developing
relationships with our friends India
Japan South Korea you know we need to
start focusing on the Philippines let's
build up our relationship with Arab
countries in a way that we can go and
defeat Iran those are the things that
that's better effective time than to go
and sit there and and pay too much
attention to these um organizations
where all they do is talk about issues
over and over again and they never do
anything and by the way Iran now where
if a woman is not does not cover her
head uh could be murdered and get the
death penalty or if you're discovered to
be gay or lesbian they're going to
they're going to kill you in Iran uh and
give you the death penalty they are now
the head of the UN Human Rights
Commission that's not even a bad joke
that is that is how corrupt that
organization is so my final leadup
question is this should America once and
for all cut ties with all of these
globalist organizations and if you ever
became president would you do
that if I become president we will get
out of the Human Rights Council we would
certainly not get back into the Paris
climate agreement get out of we get out
of the World Health Organization the UN
the only thing is we would defund the UN
as much as possible the only reason Sean
you don't get out of the UN is we're one
country of five that has a veto and the
number of things we were able to stop
China Russia and Iran from doing with
that veto matters and so you keep bad
things from happening but we don't have
to pay the level that we're paying and
we don't have to be in any of those
other
organizations all right Ambassador Nikki
hilly thank you so much for being with
us we appreciate it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else